is
well i think i'll start with another
microphone and see if this one
yeah let's see it should be on okay can
people on zoom
hear me through this one yes oh okay
wonderful awesome
great then i think are we all set to
start
yeah why don't i just quickly introduce
you and then get started so
um so the next talk will be given by
greg kahanamoko meyer and he's going to
tell us about classical verification
of quantum computational advantage so
please craig
awesome thank you so much for the
introduction yeah um
also thanks so much for inviting me i'm
super excited to to give this talk um
this is some work that i've been doing
with
my advisor in the physics department
here at berkeley
norm yao as well as with umesh and also
with
suman choi who was a miller post doc
here at berkeley and is now faculty at
mit
so um right oh
let's see if we can advance the slides
there we go
um so right today what i'm going to be
talking about is this idea of black
box proofs of quantumness so this is an
efficiently verifiable test
that only a quantum computer should be
able to pass and
to be just like a little bit more formal
about this
we can imagine defining it sort of like
any other you know computational proof
that we're gonna do where we have a
completeness claim where we say that
there's
um there exists some bqp prover um that
causes the verifier to accept with high
probability
and that for all bpp provers the
verifier accepts with low probability
and um i think this is kind of like a
fun thing because it's not like we're
trying to prove any particular statement
or anything like that what we're really
trying to demonstrate is that you know
we're contained in like or we have some
particular computational power
um and so there's a few things that i'd
like to emphasize here
um so the first is that in this
situation the verifier is fully
classical and also the communications
are fully classical so we never allow
you know any amount of
um you know measuring like single qubits
or something like that
um the prover is a single black box
so you know irma mentioned that there
are some protocols in which we have you
know two
provers that can't communicate and this
gives us some extra power um
but in this case um like in the talk
that emerald is giving
we're just gonna use computational
assumptions and interact with a single
sort of like classically communicating
black box
and sort of something that i think is
kind of neat
um is that the soundness proof doesn't
actually know anything about quantum
mechanics so what we're actually trying
to do really is
disprove the null hypothesis that the
prover we're interacting with is
classical
um really i mean the model of
computation that we know might be able
to do this is quantum mechanics so in
some sense it's a proof of quantumness
but
maybe to be slightly more precise we
would even call it like a proof of
non-classicalness
so um there's a couple of situations in
which this sort of test might be
interesting
one is just to do like a really powerful
refutation of the extended church during
thesis
so of course we have these experiments
you know where um
like random circuit sampling and boson
sampling where
there's kind of this goldilocks regime
that people talk about which is
where okay um you know if you do random
circuit sampling and there's no way to
efficiently verify it
you can go to a problem size where you
can demonstrate an advantage so you know
your quantum computer solves it quickly
but it takes a
really long time for a classical
computer to solve it but it's still
small enough that you can throw a whole
supercomputer at it and like check that
the results actually make sense
um but in this case because we have an
efficient verifier we can you know go to
the regime where it would take the
lifetime of the universe for a classical
supercomputer to solve it
and then uh you know still be able to
check it on our laptop which is kind of
a nice feature
um the other situation which this sort
of thing might be useful
is just you know you have some cloud
service that claims it's
you know running a quantum computer and
you want to make sure that they're not
just secretly you know simulating all of
your circuits or something like that
so you can just send some data back and
forth through the internet and then
after doing this be confident okay this
is actually you know they actually have
some
some quantum power so
turns out there's an easy way to do this
which is just to run shor's algorithm
you multiply two
large primes together send them to the
approver and ask for the factorization
um so good that was a good talk very
efficient and
that's it um but obviously you know
we want to do something slightly more
interesting than this and the reason is
that we want to do it on a near-term
device right so we want to be able to
demonstrate this sort of thing
without resorting to quantum algorithms
that you know are not feasible
on today's on today's devices
and in terms of doing this on a nist
device
there are kind of two broad paths that
we might take
so first of all we could take one of
these sampling problems
like random circuits or boson sampling
which is you know feasible on this
device which
people have already shown in experiments
and like figure out a way to add some
structure to it or something like that
to make this sort of problem have an
efficient verification scheme
classically
the other thing we can do is we can take
one of these you know number theory
problems or other algorithms which
you know we know a quick efficient way
to verify it but seem hard on this
device and figure out some way to make
it less costly
so that we can achieve both of these
goals that is both nist feasible and
efficiently verifiable
so yeah for the rest of this talk i'm
going to be talking about not sort of
you know
proofs that this sort of thing exists
but essentially ways that we can make it
uh make it faster and make it feasible
to do
in the near term okay good
so first i want to talk about this idea
of adding structure to sampling problems
generically this idea seems pretty hard
because
you know in some sense the point of of
doing you know like random circuit
sampling or something like this is that
it doesn't really have structure and it
you know mixes things up really quickly
and that's why you're able to do
uh a classically hard test in a short
amount of
of uh you know quantum volume or
something like that
um just as an example you know there was
an idea
of sampling iqp circuits which is uh you
know hamiltonians that have this sort of
structure
where we have just products of pali x's
on
various qubits and uh
about a decade ago it was shown that you
know you can hide a secret in this
hamiltonian h
such that you uh evolve for a certain
amount of time and then sample the
resulting state
and then you're going to get some
results that are correlated with this
secret
um and a little bit later there were
actually a number of papers that showed
you know that classically simulating
these hamiltonians is hard and
like average case complexity is um just
as hard as worst case and things like
that
but the the fundamental thing that was
sort of still open is that
um this hiding relied on
non-standard cryptographic assumptions
and it wasn't clear if this actually
works and it turns out that
this doesn't actually work um in the
sense that there is a classical
algorithm you can use to extract the
secret from each
um so this is just sort of an example to
demonstrate that um
while this is potentially a promising
way to go about things
it seems that it does open a lot of
opportunities for classical cheating and
it's not totally obvious how to
you know uh sort of encode
um standard cryptographic assumptions
into these sampling problems in a way
that allows the sampling problem to
still be easy on a quantum computer but
but have some you know cryptographic
weight behind it
so for the rest of this talk i'm going
to focus on the other path
which is to take one of these number
theory problems like factoring discrete
log something like that
which you know perhaps have some
efficiently verifiable protocol
and see what we can do to make them less
costly and make them risk feasible
okay so the starting point is actually
going to be
was already very nicely introduced by
irmala um
we're gonna be working with these
interactive proofs so
um the sort of like broad structure that
we're gonna use
is the following and this is just kind
of something to keep in your head
um the first round of interaction is
going to involve
the prover committing to a specific
quantum state
and then the rest you know either one or
a couple more rounds of interaction
will involve the verifier specifying to
this prover
how to measure that state and it turns
out that this kind of uh
structure is actually super duper
powerful in this context
because you know the nice thing about an
interactive proof is that you can
you can randomize the later queries or
you know and
i mean you could also have it be
adaptive but in this case we're not
going to worry about that
um and by doing this you can ensure that
the prover would respond correctly
essentially no matter which
uh which measurement basis you um you
request
the thing that's really neat about this
is you know you can only make
really one measurement of a quantum
state you know if you're doing a full
measurement then you collapse and and
you're done
but by doing this randomization and
ensuring that the prover would respond
correctly no matter what basis you ask
for you can almost do a sort of like
virtual tomography where you like
hide some you know cryptographically
secret information in the state
and then what you're saying is okay i
know that the approver actually was
holding
this information that we uh that we
cared about even though
maybe any single measurement wouldn't be
able to give me anything
cryptographically meaningful
okay so this is really cool um and this
kind of stems out of the
the first original protocol that ermelo
was talking about which i'll just
go back over really quickly just so that
we have um
so that we have an idea of of where
we're starting from
so how does the prover commit to a state
we're gonna
gonna use this this idea from that first
paper
um that was being discussed so you take
a two to one collision resistant or claw
free function
um here just we're considering one
single function it's kind of equivalent
to say you know you have two functions
f0 and f1
you can just add the single bit to the
front to make it into one function
and we're going to do this thing that
was that was discussed in the previous
talk where
the verifier picks such a function sends
it over to the prover they evaluate
the function on a uniform superposition
of the inputs
and then they're just going to measure
the second register
store that as a value y and send it back
to the verifier
so the reason that this is really neat
is that by measuring this we're going to
collapse onto a uniform superposition
of these two pre-images x0 and x1 which
we know are cryptographically hard to
hold at the same time
but because the verifier holds a
trapdoor they're able to compute the
state in full so now the verifier knows
the whole state
and the quantum provers job now is to
demonstrate
to the verifier that they actually hold
this state and their didn't just make up
some y and then send it over
so um right so in this talk in
particular we're kind of
going to stick with this um with this
uh commitment strategy rather than
modifying it like like irma was doing
and we're gonna talk more specifically
about the measurement scheme we're gonna
use on this state
so okay so this is the first round that
i just talked about
how are we going to measure this state
this is the original protocol um
from these five authors that that irma
was already discussing that
you can build based off of lwe
essentially what we're going to do is
just pick the standard of the automar
basis
send it over to the approver the prover
is going to measure each of the qubits
in the superposition
in that given basis and send the result
back and
validate that that result against x0 and
x1
so this works for the the tcf based off
of lwe
but there's a little bit of a subtlety
which is that the claw-free nature
of um of this function f
does not actually imply that it's hard
to come up with these
uh measurements directly um
in this specific case the lwe tcf has
this special cryptographic feature
called the adaptive hardcore bit
and what this says is effectively it it
directly proves um from a cryptographic
standpoint that it's hard to come up
with these
uh with these two measurements at the
same time and um
as ermila described it uh this is just
saying
that um essentially if you know one one
pre-image you can't even come up with
like you know
one bit of the other pre-image well in
this case we're just trying to say that
uh
what we'd like to say is that you know
you if you know one pre-image you can't
come up with
uh the other pre-image in full
okay so since this original protocol
there have been a number of other
trapdoor cloth refunctions that have
been suggested
for use in a protocol like this um
but we can see that you know all of them
as far as we know
other than lwe don't have this adaptive
hardcore bit property
so there's this question you know uh
what sorts of protocols can we build
that doesn't require an adaptive
hardcore bit
and there was a nice work last year
which shows
a protocol that both is non-interactive
so it's
down to just you know you send a message
and and bring it back
um and also doesn't require this
adaptive hardcore bit
and this was proven in the random oracle
model um
we might ask then is there a way that we
can remove the adaptive hardcore bit in
the standard model
for doing for example this you know
rigorous
refutation of the uh extended church
touring thesis
so the answer is yes and that's
the protocol that i'm going to talk
about now um
so just to to remind us um we're going
to start from the same protocol that we
had before where we're measuring in the
standard or the hadamard basis
after committing to a state um and then
sending back the result
but we're going to keep this measurement
in the standard basis as one of the
options
but instead of measuring in the hadamard
basis we're going to replace it with
this thing that we call the
the one player chsh gain um
which which i'll describe in a moment so
as we kind of go through at this point
the verifier picks standard basis or
play the one player chsh game and we can
show that um
with this measurement scheme you
actually don't need the adaptive
hardcore bit so i'll explain what i mean
by this now
so what we're going to do is add one
more round of interaction in this case
and um the two rounds are going to be
the following first we're going to
condense the
information held in x0 and x1 onto a
single qubit
and then we're going to do something
that's the equivalent of a bell test on
this qubit
so which might seem kind of out of left
field but i'll explain what i mean by
that it seems
uh i i like it i think it's pretty cool
so
um what the verifier does for this first
step this condensing step
is to pick a random bit string r send it
over to
uh the prover and then this right
register here is just a single qubit a
single lancilla
they're just going to compute the inner
product of x with r in the stanzilla so
you can just do this easily by applying
c naught gates from
this x0 x1 register over into the
scinzilla
then they're going to measure all of the
qubits in this x0
x1 register in the hadamard basis which
kind of you know
erases it and applies some phase um
and send the results of that measurement
back so
the thing that um one can
one can see if you work through this is
that
after this after performing this
operation you'll end up with
a single qubit state that is either 0 or
1 if
this equality is true if x0.r is equal
to x1.r
or plus or minus if this is not true but
it turns out what you can show is that
this equality is actually protected by
the cryptography so just from
the uh the fact that we have a clawfree
function where it's hard to come up with
x0 and x1
we can use the goldrick11 theorem to
show that that this
um it's it's cryptographically hard to
to get any advantage in determining this
equality so essentially what we're
saying then is
cryptographically we're protecting
whether the qubit is polarized in the z
basis
or in the x basis now this might feel a
little bit useless because you say okay
but both of these are maximally mixed
it's right so like how can we do
anything meaningful to distinguish them
well it turns out in the chsh game or in
a bell test after you measure one of the
qubits the other qubit is also in a
maximum
maximally mixed state but what you can
do is
you know generate some correlations that
even if they don't tell you anything
about the state you can still prove that
there was some kind of correlation going
on there
um so just to make it very clear in the
uh in our case the the polarization of
this qubit is hidden by the
cryptographic secret and in the chsh
case
or the bell test case um the
polarization is hidden by
uh the non-communication between the two
uh the two measurements or the two
parties that are playing the game
so um it turns out we can kind of go
straight through and just do what you
would do in a bell test or in the chsh
game
we pick an intermediate basis like the z
plus x or the z minus x basis
send it over to the approver the prover
measures the cubit in that basis and
sends a result back and then you can
just validate against these
um these various quantities that you've
gotten and and
get some correlation with the
cryptographic secret
and um so just like in a bell test or in
kind of any interactive proof
um you can come up with a classical
bound for success
so you know if we collect statistics
after you know running the protocol
sequentially many times
um we can compute two values it turns
out for the analysis it's easier to keep
them separate um
the success when you're just you know
getting a pre-image in the standard
basis versus
um when you're playing this chs search
game and
so this is the bound under the
assumption that the function's claw free
and then if you walk through the case of
the ideal quantum prover
you know running the protocol honestly
you can show that you end up
exceeding the bound by a fair amount and
one cool thing that i just wanted to
point out
is that if you just uh hold the
the probability of getting that standard
basis measurement right um
at one then sort of like
so that's for both the classical and the
quantum improver then you can
look at the probability of winning the
chsh measurement and you actually
recover the exact
uh win probabilities that you that you
have in that normal game which is kind
of nice
okay so this is the protocol
but the whole reason that i said we were
doing this was to make it uh
feasible for near-term devices right so
you might be wondering you know like
what can we do on near-term devices with
this and
um it turns out that there are you know
with this protocol or with you know the
random oracle model one or
or any of these protocols there are kind
of three okay
the the one round protocol doesn't have
this issue but
there are there are three main
challenges so one is partial measurement
right if you're going to do an
interactive proof and you're sending
classical data you have to make some
measurement in the middle um
send it over and then wait for a new
response and then and then do the next
thing
um
there's also this fidelity requirement
right so you need to pass the
uh the classical bound that i mentioned
um and i'll show that you know a
sort of generically if you run the
quantum prover and it just has a little
bit of fidelity
it will be significantly below the bound
it won't be like saturating the bounds
so we need to figure out how to deal
with that
and then lastly you know you need to run
these circuits that eval
evaluate this trapdoor clawfree function
on a quantum device and
it's not at all you know obvious like
how to make these circuits efficient
okay so for the partial measurement
thing um i just wanted to use this to
highlight
uh some really cool experimental work
that's going on
so some folks at the university of
maryland seem to be moving to duke
have been working on demonstrating these
protocols in trapped ions
and this is the team among other people
and also
you know on the theory side we've been
working with tomah
and umesh and other folks
on this as well so
the main thing i wanted to show here is
that it turns out that partial
measurements in the lab are actually
coming along
uh pretty nicely and in this trapped ion
system it turns out what they can do
is take their chain of ions and actually
modify their traps so that the the chain
splits in half
and then they zap one of these to
measure it and it's far enough away that
it doesn't actually decohere the other
set of ions
and then they bring them back together
and you know do whatever rest of the
computation they need to do
which is really cool it seems very hard
these are the moments that i'm happy
that i'm a theorist because
experimentalists seem like they have a
very difficult task in front of them but
um yeah it turns out that partial
measurements with high fidelity are
starting to come along well
and it feels like this is kind of um
yeah coming along in the experimental
setting
um the high fidelity requirement is
something we can help out with
um on the theory side it turns out by
doing
uh a kind of post-selection-based
technique
so as i mentioned before um it turns out
if you kind of like do the math
uh to pass this classical bound you need
an 83
circuit fidelity if you're just like
sort of generically running the circuits
for this problem
which is quite high right like we we'd
like to be able to pass it with like
only a little bit of fidelity for
example the the random circuit sampling
experiment you know ended up with a
cross entropy benchmark of like 0.2 or
something and that was enough to show
that there was a quantum advantage so
we'd like to be able to do a similar
thing here
it turns out you can show that if you
can get your proofer to hold this state
with this phase in between x0 and x1
kind of only having epsilon
coherence so it might be plus it might
be minus but it's plus just like epsilon
more of the time than it's minus
then you can pass the test so then the
question becomes is there some way we
can get our approver to generate this
even if it's noisy
and it turns out you can essentially
what you can do
is make sure that f x has a bunch of
redundant bits in it
and then you just post select on uh on
these values f of x after you measure
them in the first round and
make sure that they're valid right and
the assumption that's kind of implicit
here is that
uh if there's some sort of corruption in
the circuit that evaluates f
x then that'll show up as you know
corrupting this output bit string
and i'm not going to spend too long on
this but i just wanted to show that we
did some numerical experiments
and showed that sort of as we add more
and more redundancy which is measured by
this value
m here we're able to kind of push up
this curve um the x-axis is the total
circuit fidelity
and this line here is the threshold for
demonstrating advantage
and we're able to push up this curve and
as we add enough
um as we add enough redundancy this post
selection scheme allows us to kind of
bend the curve and keep it always above
the quantum advantage threshold so even
you know with only one percent circuit
fidelity we can still
still pass the classical bound okay
good so the last thing that i mentioned
that i wanted to um
that i wanted to handle in terms of
making this thing
uh feasible for for near-term
experiments
is that we have to actually evaluate the
tcf right this is kind of like the
the the thing that's been looming over
us how are we gonna do this
so getting rid of the adaptive hardcore
bit certainly helps
because it opens up these trapdoor claw
free functions based off of x squared
mod n or ring lwe that have
really fast classical circuits so
asymptotically you know you can get them
as fast as n log n though
whether that's you know feasible in
practice is another question
but the issue here is that these
classical circuits you know these
algorithms are recursive so it turns out
that they're really hard to make
reversible because you have to store
the uh the outputs of each level of
recursion so then when you continue to
recurse you can uncompute them later
the really beautiful thing about
actually all of these protocols
basically any
protocol in which you measure the second
register and then have
a polynomial number of of
of bit string superposed on the first
register is that
there's actually a way to make these
circuits irreversible with adding
essentially no overhead to the to the
classical circuit and i'll show how to
do that now
so normally right when we convert
just a classical circuit to a quantum
circuit we have these garbage bits
hanging around so if we take you know an
and gate
and we want to turn it into a toefl gate
um we have these
these inputs that we have to maintain uh
otherwise the the gate won't be unitary
and you know in general if we take an
entire classical circuit and turn it
into a unitary
um one way we can do it is just kind of
leave these garbage bits hanging around
so this is like a
circuit that's related to the uf that we
want in which we just evaluate the
classical circuit
starting with these inputs x these input
qubits you know have the output qubits f
of x and then we just have all of these
extra outputs hanging around
um which i've labeled gf of x or the
garbage bits
so i kind of i don't know if i would say
standard but a
a easy way to deal with this is to
simply
run uf prime of x copy the result via c
not gates to
some extra output register and then run
uf prime backwards and then that'll
uncompute
f x and g f of x but because we you know
c knotted the result out into this
register we can keep f of x around
now of course this is not something
that's a great idea in practice
because not only do you have to run your
circuit twice
but also the number of garbage bits here
could be
you know scales as the total number of
gates in the circuit so this can kind of
like explode polynomially
um as as you keep going you don't want
to use you know this huge polynomial
amount of space
of course there's you know for many
algorithms more efficient ways to do
this you start uncomputing bits earlier
and there's this whole pebbling problem
about you know how to how to most
efficiently do this
but the nice thing that i'll show is
that there's actually a way to
just avoid all of this um in
in this specific contest context and
what you're going to do
is just do a hadamard gate on these
qubits and then measure them um
okay this seems like you know the no
free lunch theorem like this is
way too good to be true how can you just
do this um
so let's look at what happens when we do
this we have the garbage bits we
do a hadamard measurement and we get
some output string h what we're going to
end up with
is this state where we have some phase
which depends on the outcome of the
measurement and on the values of the
garbage bits
on every term of the superposition
normally
this is like useless right because
there's a unique phase on each term that
depends on the x and like you'd have to
somehow like
compute the phase on each term of the
superposition to use it for anything
meaningful
but remember that the next thing we're
going to do in all these protocols
is measure this value f x and collapse
onto just two inputs
and once we do that g of x was based on
a classical circuit
so the verifier can just compute it
efficiently
and then knows the phase in between x0
and x1 and then it's just easy
to run the rest of the protocol without
caring about caring about what this
phase is
so the takeaway here is that you can
just directly convert classical circuits
to quantum circuits
with no overhead other than you know
doing extra measurements
and so i've you know implemented
x squared mod n using the karatsuba
multiplication algorithm which is
recursive
and for a 1024-bit multiplication
um in the abstract circuit model it only
costs 10 of the six toffley gates which
um on the one hand is like you know way
more efficient than doing
you know a normal circuit for for this
sort of thing and certainly more
efficient than like running shore's
algorithm
on the other hand ten to the sixth
hoffley gates is still a lot of toffley
gates so we we'd like to improve this
um so yeah so with that um i'd kind of
like to talk about the paths forward
from
from these protocols um
so the main uh
the main bottleneck which i hope i maybe
convinced you of from
from the past a few slides is evaluating
this trapdoor claw free function on the
superposition
and i think fixing this problem and like
running it you know
in the next year or something will
require some kind of out of the box
theory thinking um
i don't think that the experiments are
going to like magically be able to do
this in the next year
though you know hopefully not in too
long um
so some ideas and i don't mean to like
say that they're bad ideas because this
is what i've been working on so it's
kind of
sad if they're bad ideas but um so one
thing you can do is try to find say more
efficient
uh trapped or claw-free functions or
things like that um you can also
you know do these tricks that i was
talking about try to build better
quantum circuits for them and that sort
of thing
but like at a fundamental level um
of these trapdoor claw free functions
are public key cryptography right
and a lot of people have tried really
hard to make public key cryptography
fast
because you know we care about that in a
classical context and that sort of thing
and you know we want to use it on like
rfid readers or like things like that
and it's not clear if like
the best way to solve this specific
quantum problem is to try to come up
with you know
new public key cryptography that's like
more efficient than the constructions
that we already have
so maybe we'll want to take a slightly
different path
um so i call these box adjacent ideas
because they are out of the box a little
bit
um so we find uh other protocols maybe
like maybe we can
you know take this iqp protocol i was
mentioning and
and um make it more efficient and also
you know
make it uh rely on some standard
cryptographic assumptions
um maybe yeah we can build something
based off of you know more efficient
cryptography though you know then
you start to run into the question of um
you know
are you actually um
are you actually uh
you know disproving the extended church
turning thesis if if there is not
um if you're using cryptography that
doesn't have a uh
um sort of complexity theoretic
uh basis behind it um
and then maybe there's some some
way outside the box idea you know and um
i don't know maybe there are many smart
people in the room maybe they can help
figure out
some such way outside the box idea that
will allow us to do that
um so that's all i had and i think we
have like
nine minutes to discuss or chat so um
yeah if anyone has any questions or or
wants to discuss
happy to happy to talk
thanks great thank you first time giving
an in-person talk in so long it's nice
sorry oh thank you very much this was
really nice so um indeed i think we have
a bit of time for
questions and discussion um are there
any questions
either from participants on zoom or were
there at uh berkeley
so where did you avoid i guess not
familiar with where it was used before
and
oh yeah no no worries yeah let me let me
uh
maybe it's i can i can get back there
this way i just got to go through the
trap i am
shuttling um so
no this is this is a good question so
right so
here where it comes in is that um irma
will mention that
when you do this hadamard basis test you
end up with this sort of equation test
where you're saying
um you you aren't able to come up with
an equation
that's like some string d dot x zero
plus x one you know equals zero say
right and um where it comes in is
is it turns out it's not very hard to
actually come up with a
function that's just claw free where
it's easy to come up with that sort of
equation um essentially what you can say
is
you know or another way of saying it is
the
um to pass this test you only need to
know one bit
of of the other pre-image after you know
one of the preimages
or sort of like the parity of some
subset of the bits of the other
pre-image
um so that's fundamentally what the
adaptive far core bit
comes in is is saying that if you're
going to do this hadamard basis test you
need
you need that output to actually be hard
and where you get around it is that when
you do
this operation right um the hardness of
figuring out this equality or getting
some advantage in figuring out this
equality
depends on knowing every single bit of
x0 and x1
and one way of looking at this is that
right originally
the prover was picking some string d and
asking for the inner product between
b and x0 and x1 here instead the
verifier is picking that
so because the verifier picks it the
approver can't you know
pick some specific bits that they happen
to know how to do something good with
um the verifier just doesn't then
they're they're stuck
um so that's yeah that's where it comes
in
so our r is kind of like the analog of t
yeah exactly and it's a little bit
confusing because there's this other d
because you do still do a measurement on
these things
um so there's kind of two related things
but this d ends up
just affecting the phase on these two
and since we care about the polarization
and not the phase
that d that the prover comes up with
ends up not matter and cryptographically
you can just kind of throw it away
yeah and you said you had another
question i think
okay oh yeah i think there's a i see a
hand raised on zoom
right so yeah i think maybe dan do you
want to ask your question dan bernstein
actually the tanya part of janetania um
i was intrigued
i was intrigued by the um mentioning of
of other cryptographic primitives can
you kind of
pin down what is your cost function so
there is now some uh area of recent
development where there's algebraic
ciphers which are trying to reduce the
number of multiplications so the number
of nonlinear operations
and that sounds a bit like it should be
happy also for
uh quantum computation
wow that sounds yeah really great uh i
don't
really know if i can like contribute too
much
in an answer to that um i guess to ask
you a quick question what exactly do you
mean by like
what do you mean by your cost function
like um
i guess yeah do you mind just clarifying
a little bit sure
i did my best in paying attention but i
probably don't grasp all the things that
contribute to the expenses here and so
can you kind of summarize what parts are
really expensive
so for instance mutation i've been doing
but
binary and you're working mod n um but i
assume that multiplications are a lot
more expensive than say editions but you
still have to do this carry so that also
sounds expensive
yeah yeah okay that's a really good
point so
right there are kind of a a number of um
a number of different ways of uh
you know of implementing this arithmetic
and there are some kind of inherently
quantum algorithms that can improve on
uh improve on on ways to implement this
but
fundamentally yeah what you end up doing
um to implement for example x squared
mod n
is um i mean so
say take like the school book the school
book algorithm for
for multiplication which it turns out
actually performs pretty well for
computing x squared mod n
you're just kind of doing the standard
thing where you take you know like
products of
of individual bits and then like add
them into a register and like sum up
every individual product
um and then algorithms like the
karatsuba algorithm
you're kind of like you know breaking up
the multiplication into several pieces
and then
and then using them in a clever way but
fundamentally what ends up being
expensive is just doing
a lot of additions um or you know
however you want to implement your
multiplication but but in general it's
like the additions that end up
uh being the fundamental cost does that
help
but you don't care about say ancillary
bits because i mean covered super is
pretty bad for that normally
sorry could you say it again it's a
little hard to hear you through the
speakers oh but you don't care about say
the space complexity so you don't know
how many answers you need
oh sure i mean you so you do certainly
care about the space complexity just in
the sense that you don't expect
near-term
quantum devices to have you know a large
amount of space
so um you know for example this is why i
was
saying in this garbage bit idea you
don't really want to just
you know run the circuit and then
uncompute it by running it in reverse
because you end up with a polynomial
number of bits
so it certainly is like very
very helpful to uh to to try to reduce
the the space complexity and i mean one
thing that you can consider
is um sort of like the quantum the
quantum volume like
one one trivial weighted or not trivial
but one easy way to measure it is just
you multiply like the width of the
circuit by the depth
and and ask you know uh
and use that as kind of a rough idea of
how expensive your circuit is if that
helps
okay so then just as a recommendation if
you're looking for alternatives
alternatives uh maybe look at the
algebraic ciphers from the symmetric
crypto world
so that could be interesting or shoot me
an email if you want pointers
yeah thank you so much definitely
definitely appreciate that i'm excited
to explore
hey great it looks like there are also
two uh questions they both look like
good questions uh in the q a maybe i can
just read them um
so first there's a question from
chinengchu who asks do you have an
estimate about how many qubits are
needed to demonstrate quantum supremacy
using your protocol
for example you know would the with a
256 cubic quantum simulator like the one
from lucan's group be enough
okay really good question yeah so um
what it comes down to is you know
which trapdoor clawfree function are you
going to use so um
you know i also um we have in this paper
um a tractor clawfree function based off
of
uh decisional diffie-hellman which is
you know kind of analogous to
or closely related to the discrete log
problem um
and the nice thing about this is that if
you do it over elliptic curves
you can kind of cut down the space by a
lot so i think you could
show in sort of the abstract circuit
model
um quantum advantage using like
i think it should be like 300 cubits or
something but the problem with this is
you have to do electric curve
cryptography
in a quantum circuit so um so you know
if you're trying to actually implement
this
you're only using 300 cubits but the
number of gates you have to do is like
super large so this probably isn't super
um practical unless you can come up with
some really you know clever quantum way
to do elliptic curve cryptography
um on using x square mod n which you
know has
these fairly efficient quantum circuits
um
the issue you run into there is just
that like in terms of classical
computers are pretty good at factoring
even if it is
ultimately you know uh super exponential
or sorry
super polynomial um so
uh you need probably like you know a few
thousand qubits
just to sort of like hold the problem
and to do the computation if you're
using x squared mod n
um which yeah is is probably more than
you know
devices right now have
okay thanks and maybe we have time also
to answer the other question if you're
willing so
um there's also a question from vinod so
again i'll just read it so he says um
you know this is a very nice protocol
and something quite general seems to be
going on
uh you seem to be compiling a
multi-proofer game into a single prover
one using cryptographic ideas
um so the concrete question is this is
it possible to do something like this
for other games so for example for the
magic ware game
yeah thank you thank you for this
question it's it's a really good
question and it's actually something
i've thought about and also been asked
about it other talks
um so people seem very interested in it
and i'm happy yeah definitely to chat
more about it if people want to
want to think about it um what it comes
down to so i actually
specifically tried you know oh can we do
a similar thing but with magic square
um the first thing is
while this would just be interesting
kind of from a theory perspective it's
not clear if it helps in terms of the
implementation
thing i mean magic square is nice
because you get the 100
um you know success rate for the quantum
prover
but the uh classical one can still do
like quite well right so um so
i don't think that for example i had to
do this post selection for the fidelity
thing i don't think it would
particularly help in terms of like
you know improving the fidelity that you
need um for that
sort of thing um the other thing just
you know if you say well whatever i'm
just interested in this and i want to do
it anyway
um what you have to figure out is like
the the reason that this sort of thing
works is
this polarization of this qubit just
sort of like pops out
of doing this protocol um and you know
normally you measure one qubit and then
you have this other qubit and you
um and it happens to be in the same
state as this but there's no
like at least to me super obvious
generic way to generate
the states of magic square after one
person has measured
out of a cryptographic protocol like
this so i mean what you essentially have
to do and what i did on my whiteboard is
you can like you know list out each of
the possible outcomes of doing this
measurement in magic square and then
like
try to figure out how you can get these
outcomes to pop out of your
cryptographic protocol
in such a way that which outcome you
have depends on
uh the cryptography in sort of like a
cryptographically strong way
um so yeah to me there's no obvious like
uh
generic way to do this but maybe there's
one hiding in there and that would be
really cool if someone figures that out
okay thanks um are there any other
questions there in the room
i can't see but um
yeah of course basically for this
protocol
you're kind of saying if there is a so
any classical algorithm that passes
with more than 75 percent
an anniversary that recovers the two yes
yes um and so here in the analysis you
can assume your adversary is classical
right um do you manage to get any handle
on the state of the trooper
that's a really good question yeah
so this is a really good question it's
something i've thought about a little
but haven't super duper explored
um but this is definitely an interesting
next direction is you know asking
okay yeah irma was discussing you know
how we can use this sort of protocol to
for example certify randomness
it's like can you actually use this
protocol to do a similar thing to
certified randomness and i
don't know the answer right now it's an
interesting thing to explore for sure
for sure
okay great are there any other questions
okay well if not let's um let's thank
greg again
so thanks very much and uh we're we're
right on time so it's perfect
so um uh is tony giving the talk on zoom
or
yeah i'm on zero okay
great so